[Musique]
en attaque ça oui oui j'aime la grosseur
des morceaux en tartare comme ça est
parfaite c'est vraiment une viande qui
se prête très bien aux startups et arès
juteuse
[Musique]
ici le yak 3 nous sommes chez les
bédouins couture lacroix à bolton est en
estrie à la ferme ya qui tient depuis
2016 le couple élève ses bovidés et
aujourd'hui leurs propos comme 57 bête
mais à peu près sept mille cinq cents
animaux des yaks un peu partout en
amérique du nord a commencé plus dans
l'ouest canadien c'est descendu aux
états unis il ya de plus en plus d'elle
par la new york dans le vermont au
québec il y avait un éleveur qui était
en gaspésie puis ils ont pris leur
retraite qu'ils nous ont vendu à plus le
plus gros de leurs troupes
[Applaudissements]
confortable dans tous les climats ici
des bêtes passent la majorité de leur
temps dans les pâturages à se nourrir
d'herbe
l'eia qu'on élève ici sont pas nourris
de la même façon que les yaks au tibet
puis y ont pas le même environnement
souvent au tibet ils vont regarder les
scènes sur les cornes pour savoir l'âge
d'un yack parce qu'ils sont en
malnutrition pendant l'hiver tandis
qu'ici bâillon du foin à l'année puis
sont super bien nourris fait qu'il n'y a
pas eu pas le même goût disons au niveau
de la texture ça va ressembler à leurs
inial étant donné que c'est pas gros
mais au niveau du goût ça a vraiment sa
particularité les skis je vous dirais
que c'est vraiment proche d'un boeuf
élevé en pâturage uniquement à l'herbe
puis c'est la technique qu'on utilise
ici
c'est le lainage abondant dit hacker qui
permet à l'animal de réguler sa
température corporelle et donner une
viande maigre c'est une viande qui se
prête très bien à la transformation
le tartare de yacks et préparé de façon
classique on prend notre porteur qui est
déjà pré coupe les oignons câpres
cornichons et petites sauces maison
malgré la très faible teneur en gras le
juteux et quand même effectivement pas
le goût plus férus de certaines viandes
le carpaccio on est allé avec la
simplicité j'ai pris simplement de la
vie en a fondu un petit peu de la livre
un petit peu de neige balsamique et
copeaux de parmesan un texte on est un
peu différent
moi je la trouve soyons toujours les
monsois lieu et le moment fait pour
renverser effectivement
c'est quoi la quantité de viande que
vous pouvez soutirer d'un animal en fait
on peut avoir avec un animal disons deux
ans et demi trois ans n'ont pas les
chercher environ 150 170 livres de
viande c'est pas énorme mais c'est pas
suffisant pour pouvoir alimenter des
épiceries non pas encore pas encore mais
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a acheté le
mec c'est le marché proximité la fusée
qui est juste en bas de la côte pour
pouvoir justement faire notre mise en
marché direct pim le but est aussi de
mettre en valeur les producteurs du coin
c'est donc au dépanneur la fusée que
nous avons donné rendez vous à son
boucher francis
coutume pour la franchise est parfait
pour faire des carpaccio avec alain
demain je les ai assez mince ça va être
super génial parce qu'on parle beaucoup
aux bisons réveil c'est pour la découpe
standard de beurre beaucoup beaucoup de
techno - dans le lien social via l'achat
de yack la fondue la telle qu'elle a
même joli rouge foncé ou qu'un gros d'un
aucun persia le faux filet de red book
plutôt lui qui méritait bien un petit
peu de personnages à la boucherie je
fais la sauce us la saucisse bec un
fromage que nouvelle sorte que
jean-philippe nous a demandés pour cent
pour cent et accès 72% et acquis 30% pas
pour avoir un petit peu de goût selon
sarah était trop maigre est beaucoup
trop sec au bout
[Musique]
mais pourquoi vous avez décidé de
devenir éleveur de yack on cherchait
enfin le retour à la terre puisqu'on
cherche est un animal qui était bien
adapté à notre climat puis à notre
environnement qui répondent à nos
valeurs de respect de la nature et de
l'environnement et il va manger deux à
trois fois moins qu'un bref régulier
mais avec toutes les qualités que vous
venez d'énumérer pourquoi ya pas
davantage d'élevage de yack repris ma
question c'est une viande qui coûte pas
trop cher à produire mais étant donné
l'étendue d'un temps puis le délai entre
la naissance pire l'abattage
cesser ce coup là qu'il faut assumer
piètre basse et éventuellement on espère
qu'ils avaient plus de plus en plus de
producteurs qui vont suivre notre
démarchage pire c'est un peu seul bull
de se développer nous on veut avoir une
certaine croissance mais on veut quand
même resté à échelle humaine pour
essayer de respecter le plus possible le
territoire au point l'environnement
[Musique]